c'est incontestablement un problème
facteurs quelle est votre opinion
pour moi il n'ya pas de doute possible
si nous décidons de faire une tombola
pour améliorer les installations du
jardin il faut que ce soit une grande
tombola et on ne peut pas faire de
grande tombola
si le gagnant le gagne-pain jolie peau
est pas vrai je crois que vous avez
raison fekter mais est ce que l'argent
et les avants réserve pour sûr on ne
pourront pas faire des folies
mais j'ai de quoi acheter quelques lots
intéressants et à mon avis ce ne sera
pas une dépense inutile
non parce que plus les lots sont
intéressants et bien plus tôt nous nous
vendons de billets ce qui veut dire ce
que si nous dépensons davantage pour les
longs nous gagnerons davantage avec la
vente des billets mais tout à fait
d'accord avec vous facteurs non l'avait
convaincu quels sont les prix auquel
vous allez penser à
et bien tout d'abord il y aura une belle
pièce de 50 cents
mais elle est superbe à faire un très
bon prix oui puis c'est assez rare
il a ensuite il y aura un trimestre
c'est-à-dire trois mois où les 90 jours
de caramel gratuit à raison de deux
carats mails par jour trois mois de
caramel gratuit mais ça aussi c'est un
pays formidable
bah oui coûté si on fait le calcul ça
fait 90 x 2 égale 120 180 à 10 centimes
le caramel ça fait un lot de 2,18
renvoie là et quels seront les autres
prix ah bon il y aura encore eu un
billet de 10 francs une pièce de 5
francs et un magnifique objet d'art un
magnifique objet d'art absolument pas
soit on ne peut pas faire de grande
tombola
sans un magnifique objet d'art et quelle
sera sa valeur alors là je lui ai
consacré tout l'argent qu'il me restait
c'est à dire deux fois une front
d'accord avec cette somme là on pourra
faire quelque chose de bien
à vrai dire factor ça dépend surtout du
talent des artistes qui nous nous
demanderons à monsieur du snob pour ce
prix là il nous fera un véritable
chef-d'oeuvre
espérons qu'il n'y a pas trop d'artistes
qui nous écoutent et que monsieur du ce
ne sera pas surpris par cette somme
bonjour tout le monde
bonjour décrire comment te porte et tu
aujourd'hui mais très bien je suis en
pleine forme de bonne humeur
j'ai fait une bonne sieste et j'ai envie
de danser pendant qu'on me faire plaisir
tu vas bien nous danser un petit accent
dallas d'accord ah bah alors musica
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
tue-t-il formidable à casimir ça
mériterait d'être un prix dans notre
tombola
une tombola quel tombola est là la
grande tombola annuelle au profit du
jardin de l'île aux enfants
nous venons d'en décider des lots roi
nous avait décidé tout ça sans moi
alors chaque fois qu'il ya quelque chose
d'intéressant à faire vous attendez que
je ne sois pas là pour le faire oh ne
crois pas ça casimir et nous n'avons pas
pensé que cela pouvait intéresser
comment vous savez très bien que ça
m'intéresse casimir du est vraiment trop
capricieux
enfin nous pouvons pas t'attendre à
chaque fois qu'il faut faire quelque
chose me nommer chaque fois qu'il y a
quelque chose d'amusant nous attendent
et que je sois parti
bon ben écoute nous allons tout donner
une responsabilité importante
tu va classer les prix ça te plaît ah
oui oui d'accord
bon je ne suis plus de mauvaise humeur
du tout heureusement alors voilà casimir
tu vas marquer alors classé le premier
prix le deuxième bien le troisième
ancien le 4e et enfin le cinquième à
droite tient en classe les parfaits
d'ici là c'est très facile et casimir tu
n'oublies pas le premier prix doit être
le plus beau lot non enfin françois pour
qui me prend qu'une excuse
or toutes les sources voyons très bien
bombe à 10 francs fera un très beau
premier prix voilà
un bon 5 francs fera un deuxième prix
parfait en 3e prix je mettrai les 50
francs voilà 4e prix mettons de francs
et un bas 18 rond le dernier le
cinquième prix voilà en soi un facteur
oui j'ai cassé les prix un plat pour sûr
ça ne va pas du tout casimir casimir
sois gentil d'y réfléchir un petit peu
bien voyons voyons voir au luc tu ne
fais rien bien mais des voilages tu
expliques tu voles ya cinq prix et il
faut mettre à gauche en premier prix la
plus forte somme la télé 5 ans vont
mêler le deuxième prix qu'est ce que ce
sera le 10 8 après 58 très bien d'accord
bonne idée
le troisième prix qu'est ce que l'on
peut mettre voilà troisièmes prix 10
ensuite le quatrième le quatrième c'est
18 ou attend 5 ou 2 5 d'accord valeur le
dernier ces deux voilà ça y est facteur
et françois les prix sont classés j'ai
trouvé la faille j'ai trouvé avec l'aide
de l'udc pour ceux en voie la plus belle
liste de prix possible bravo bon voilà
tous les deux il ne reste plus qu'à
aller demander à monsieur du snop sont
magnifiques objets d'art moi je
n'écrirai pas tellement quand moi je
veux bien y aller
bon ben écoute casimir relate deux
francs 1 tu choisiras le plus bel objet
d'art au score le plus beau vous pouvez
compter sur moi
de francs
[Musique]
vraiment ça commence à faire longtemps
qu'il est parti facteurs et moi je suis
inquiet mais pourquoi ils doivent
hésiter sur le choix de l'objet et pour
2 francs
il doit pas y avoir grand chose vous
trouvez que c'est passé il me semble oui
oh mais regardez françois le voilà qui
arrive
casimir que spassky monsieur du ska
madic pour 2 francs qu ils n'avaient
rien à vendre
mais que de toute façon à ce prix là il
ne connaissait qu'un seul magnifiques
objets d'art ma tête
[Musique]